It's breathtaking
when you see sand here imagine water
if you dive in you can't reach the
bottle you dive in yes it's cold
swimming I don't I don't believe you
have you ever had a dream about your first ride
don't try to impress anyone
you're brave we don't know
that be simple be direct
nothing fancy I understand
we gave them something to hope for. That's not hope!
May thy knife chip and shatter
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
Dune Part 2 Trailer video there's a whole bunch of
stuff going on so we'll break it all down it's
basically covering the second half of the first
book which is why the title is Dune part two and
by the title Dune part 1 appeared in the first
movie if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos so I'll just
start at the beginning of the trailer footage and
work our way through shot by shot talking about
Easter eggs WTF moments and all the new characters
that they didn't cover in the first movie and some
returning characters that people thought might
have died during the first movie but even if you
haven't read the actual book you've probably seen
the David Lynch movie or you've seen the Sci-Fi
mini-series which covered more of the books than
the original David Lynch movie The David Lynch
movie was kind of like a speed run version of the
entire first book crammed down into two hours the
plot of Doom part 1 and dune part two like these
new movies is meant to be much more book accurate
than even the Sci-Fi mini series which is like
the next closest thing to the actual books but
they begin the trailer with Paul and chani joking
about his first try to try and ride a sand worm
like trying to call a sand worm and write it on
his own they teased that at the end of Dune part
1 but he was with all the other fremen who called
the Worm for him so he just rode along with them
he didn't call it by himself try to write it by
himself which is why still gar is joking with
him too don't try to impress us don't do anything
fancy and Paul is like yeah okay nothing fancy got
it and the reason why he looks so surprised at the
end of the trailer when he actually calls the worm
and winds up writing it is because the one that
he calls winds up being ginormous like damn he
wasn't kidding he does have some crazy Powers
also love the way that he's joking with chani
about the idea of water like he's talking about
the water at the beginning of the trailer in all
the sieges underground because Iraqis used to be a
paradise Planet before it was turned into a desert
before the sand worms came they were brought by a
bunch of monks and then turned the planet into a
desert and created what they call the cycle of the
sand worms in the spice basically the sand worms
babies create the spice but the idea is that Paul
is having these dreams thinking about the water
and turning the planet back into a paradise the
problem with that though is that if you turn it
back into a paradise it essentially kills off the
worms and that kills off the spice so it's meant
to be a double-edged sword like damned if you do
damned if you don't it's one of the problems with
Paul's powers like he sees potential Futures and
thinks that he's leading them along the best path
the golden pass so to speak in the joke with her
not understanding swimming is because she always
grew up in the desert like there were no bodies
of water where she could learn to swim so the
whole concept of swimming is foreign to her like
what swimming what are you talking about one of
the other big changes between Dune part 2 and
dune part 1 is that chani becomes a much bigger
character people were asking about this when the
first movie came out because there wasn't a whole
lot of Zendaya during that movie she only really
appeared in Paul's visions at the very beginning
of the movie and then later in the movie once
he actually starts to meet the friend like oh
wait a minute you're the girl in all my dreams the
idea is that through this movie their relationship
develops even though it doesn't seem like a lot
of time passes there is a lot of time passing in
the background like the events of the sequel
don't happen overnight then we hear the voice
over from Princess Irulin played by Florence Pugh
she actually looks fantastic really interested to
see what she does with the character she starts
talking about the secrets of arrakis and dangerous
things in the desert she's talking about Paul
Atriedes surviving like what if he survived he's
going to come back and seek revenge for what you
did against him because she knows what her father
did the emperor did to get rid of House Atriedes
and when she's talking about the secrets of the
desert you actually see Lady Jessica who since
become the Reverend mother of the fremen that's
why she has all the tattoos all over her face
during the trailer you also hear her arguing
with Paul talking about how she tried to give them
a fighting chance and help them survive the Hawaii
at the beginning of Dune part 1 is that the people
thought that Paul was the Savior that they had
been dreaming of but it was really part of the
Bene Gesserit kind of laying the foundation for
that and when things went sideways in the first
movie when the harkonnens attacked and they needed
to survive lady Jessica and Paula talk about sort
of fitting in the role like why don't we just
pretend like I'm that savior so it becomes sort of
a self-fulfilling prophecy and in the trailer here
for part two lady Jessica is just talking about
that like oh try to give us a fighting chance
that's why I became the river mother of these
people it it's hard to tell where princess the
rulin is when she's talking about Paul Atreides
and his mother eventually she does make her way
to arrakis but you do see Selusa secundus you do
see more of the emperor in his court during Dune
part 2. also one of the other big changes is that
princess Irulan's father Emperor shaddam IV is
being played by Christopher Walken of all people
I wouldn't have picked him for the character we'll
be interested to see what he does with it but
the whole conflict that plays out through the
movie was orchestrated by the emperor the point
is that preceding the events of the first movie
Leto Atriedes he becomes so popular so powerful
within the land straw sort of like the ruling body
amongst all the great houses inside the universe
that it caused the emperor to get paranoid and
jealous so he orchestrated a plot to use the
harkonnens to get rid of Leto Atreides he's also
kind of paranoid about the hearkenings as well
growing powerful enough growing Rich enough to
supplant him so he was hoping that in the fight
against the hearkenings against the Atreides,
the Atreides would also get rid of a lot of the
Harkonnens and weaken their house as well so they
wouldn't be able to challenge him so the emperor
is trying to play Game of Thrones so to speak on
an Intergalactic scale on a universal scale with
the hearkenings against the Atreides but a big
part of this during the first movie is when Paul
says well the emperor doesn't have a son to take
his throne but his daughter is also unwed so I
could always wed his daughter take the Golden
Throne and become the emperor of the universe
and solve all these problems so that whole plot
continues to play out in the background along
with the harkonnen versus Atriedes plot you see
the harkinens burning the bodies of the dead of
tradies after the attack from the first movie this
is them burning the pictures basically everything
from lito atrates out of the palace when it says
fury will rise and Lady Jessica is talking to
Paul about his father not believing in revenge
it seems that she hasn't become Reverend mother
of the fremen yet but the idea is that he wants
to use the fremen to get rid of the Harkonnens and
deal with the problem with the emperor the other
real Sly reference here when she says your father
didn't believe in revenge is a reference to events
preceding the events of the first movie so the
whole idea is that Paul Atriedes is actually the
Second Son of Leto Atreides what wound up
happening before the events of the first
movie Baron Harkonnen had orchestrated a plot to
kill the Duke but It ultimately led to the death
of his first son and his first Legal Wife who
killed herself after the death of the first son
it broke Leto Atreides eventually lady Jessica
became his concubine and when she got pregnant
with his child chose for it to become a male to
become Paul so that she could replace the dead
son that he lost so when she says your father
didn't believe in revenge is the idea that he
didn't declare war like open war against the baron
over the death of his first son during the first
movie he had visions of fighting the emperor's
men the sardicar as well as the hearkenings that's
basically playing out through this movie like his
Visions are coming to pass a big part of that is
in training the fremen Warriors who already vary
fears in the fighting ways of the Bene Gesserit
like the secret fighting techniques as well as
the secret fighting techniques developed by the
Atreides speaking of House of treaty's fighting
techniques you see Josh Brolin's Gurney come
back who you believe Eve may have died during
the first movie obviously if you've read the
book you know he survives or if you've seen
any other Dune movies of the miniseries then
we see Austin Butler's fade for the first time
obviously looks a little more book accurate than
the sting version during the David Lynch movie
the whole idea is that fade is meant to be The
Baron's other nephew the son of his brother
who abdicated the throne allowing the baron
to become the baron in the first place he's meant
to be rabon's younger brother and the one who the
baron favors even though rabban is useful to him
Rabon is kind of like an animal like a wild animal
the baron just uses to squeeze people fate is the
person the baron views as his potential successor
there's a quick montage of them sabotaging
the harkonnen's equipment this is actually
Léa Seydoux who's playing Lady Margot fenrig wife
of count fenrik she's another member of the Bene
Gesserit who plays a minor role during the books
I think they've expanded it for the movie her
husband count fenrig was the former Governor
of Arrakis before the Atreides and she'd been
ordered as part of the quitsat satirak breeding
program to seduce fade and get his genetic
material the same way that lady Jessica had
been ordered to do so with Duke Leto at tradies
producing Paul even though he wasn't supposed to
be born a male this just seems like a scene of the
fremen actually going to one of their underground
bases this actually seems like the Water of Life
which Paul takes to awaken his powers fully and
Lady Jessica takes when she becomes the Reverend
mother of the fremant Awakening her powers even
more obviously she doesn't get nearly as powerful
as Paula does the other big thing here too is Lady
Jessica's daughter who she's still pregnant with
when she takes the Waters of life that means the
baby also takes the Waters of Life potentially
creating what they call the Abomination one of
the problems is that when you take the Waters of
life you basically gain access to all the previous
memories of anyone who's ever lived and if you're
not powerful enough it can drive you mad and turn
you into a monster which is what the Bene Gesserit
are afraid of which is why they tested Paul and
almost killed him if he didn't pass the test you
see a scene of Paul fighting with the Crysknife
here the Crysknives are taken from the teeth of
the worms I think that all the black and white
scenes of fade fighting in the Gladiator pits
here are on Geidi Prime the harkonnen home world
and its Margot lady Margot watching fate as part
of her mission to seduce him and get his genetic
material then they have the funny scene with him
actually trying to call the worm and write it by
himself for the first time the funny thing about
stilgar here when he's joking with him like don't
try to impress anyone don't kill yourself trying
to impress us is that at this point stillgar isn't
super impressed with Paul like he understands that
he can learn their ways but he doesn't fully
believe in him as this quitsat satirak being
so over the course of the second movie he makes
Believers of the fremen they did a version of
this scene during the David Lynch movie as well
as the miniseries on sci-fi when chani is talking
to Paul saying you'll never lose me that's the
whole idea that he knows that he has to marry
the emperor's daughter as his Legal Wife but he
will retain chani as his concubine like his true
love the end of the trailer is then basically
showing you the end of the movie where he winds
up fighting fade in combat saying may your knife
chip and shatter that's right out of the books is
Bay basically this scene from the David Lynch
movie but the thing with Paul Atriedes is that
as a potential quitsat's cataract his one job as
ordained by this whole Benedict breeding program
is to lead all of Humanity on the golden path
the golden path is what the benedjesuit call
their concept of a perfect timeline like what is
the best timeline for Humanity and they call that
the golden path so over thousands of years they
try to create this super being through a breeding
program that can see that perfect timeline and
tell everyone how to bring about those events
within the Dune series the term quits at sadarach
literally translates to shortening of the way as
in finding a quicker way to a better future
so that's why they were trying to create this
super being I don't want to talk too much about
the story Beyond Dune part 2 because even though
Paul does wind up drinking the Water of Life
to fully awaken his powers like we see during
the original Dune movie The Water of Life being
the bile of the sand worms and it does amplify
his powers exponentially but Dune part 2 if you
haven't read that first book or you never watched
the original movie is still very much focused on
the immediate problem the war between Paul the
fremen the Harkonnens and the emperor everything
with Paul trying to reckon with the golden path
timeline does it really become a huge deal until
the next story after that Children of Dune God
emperor of Dune and for the most part is actually
Paul's son lito atrates II who has to reckon with
the golden path and during the ending of Dune part
1 during this first movie they kind of foreshadow
this Paul can see a version of the golden path
this future that the Bena Jesuit are looking for
but during this scene when they're in the tent
Paul starts having this nightmare ranting about
wars being fought under his Banner atrocities
being committed in his name all over the universe
people being slaughtered Everywhere by his
followers and it frightens him he's horrified
by it so in those Visions what he is seeing is
one of the possible iterations of the golden
path timeline so he actually becomes too afraid
to pursue the golden path himself he kind of runs
from it because he can't stand the thought of all
this death and destruction action being done in
his name like this doesn't sound better this
is worse if you've ever heard anybody refer to
the Dune story as a warning for the Savior Trope
that's what they're talking about and they really
won't get into that till the sequels I think till
after doing part two like if they make Doom part 4
part 5 they do God emperor of Dune so that's why
I say his son lito trades II really has to deal
with pursuing the golden path and why Paul isn't
really the quitsats atarak that everyone thinks
he is during the Dune movie or even Dune part
2. it's really his son who's the true quitsats
atarak there's an Easter egg for that at the
beginning of Dune part one when mohayam is
coming to given the test and Jessica kind of
explains the whole concept of their breeding
program they say that we believe this person that
we're trying to create is very near it's meant to
be a bit of a misdirect because Paul is standing
very near like oh he's meant to be this powerful
person but really it winds up being his son to
be this perfect being that they thought they
were creating but here's the thing mohayam says
that they have other irons in the fire like if
Paul winds up dying we have other candidates
other prospects out there in the universe
so there are many other people who can have the
same type of powers to see potential Futures and
have knowledge of the past but in most of these
other people the powers are much more limited
Paul's sister for instance who's still a fetus
inside Jessica's womb right now at the end of June
part one also gains the same kind of powers when
Jessica takes the water of life but like I said
the next big thing that's going to be happening
is Paul learning the ways of the fremen becoming
one of them starting his relationship with chani
then helping teach the benad Jesuit the house of
treaties secret fighting techniques to the fremen
to make them even more powerful than the starter
car then Paul orchestrating his original plan
that he had before everything went down to cease
all this hostility in the universe between the
Harkonnens the emperor by marrying the emperor's
daughter princess arulon if you spotted any other
Easter eggs or references during the trailer that
I didn't talk about during the video there's so
much that we could talk about obviously like super
dense book and it's just the first book in the
line of many books hopefully they do get to make
more sequels and cover the events of the other
books the movie's not coming out till November so
it'll probably be a little while before we get the
next trailer but of course I'll do more videos as
as we get more footage my Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 post credit scene video full Easter
eggs breakdown for the movie will be coming out in
a couple days just because the movie is releasing
in theaters be sure to go see it as soon as
possible everyone click here for all my Guardians
of the Galaxy videos I'll update the link as
soon as I start posting those and click here
for my brand new secret Invasion trailer video
which is the next big episodes coming up pretty
soon too thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!